voilà système d n'ayant plus de frigo
obligé de chercher les denrées
alimentaires puisque les produits frais
virenque 300 légumes dans des caisses
isothermes
une semaine après le vol de leur camion
frigorifique
les bénévoles de la croix rouge pour
suivre les collectes tant bien que mal
mais aujourd'hui la conservation des
produits frais devient de plus en plus
difficile là on a bougé de tous
manipulés à la main mais dans des
caisses isothermes des caisses
isothermes les transporter les ramener à
lui l'unité locale pour les décharger
dans les frigos ça fait beaucoup de
changements de température faut savoir
qu'on a quand même 250 familles à
nourrir près de 600 bouches à nourrir
donc c'est vrai que pour nous le bon
vieux camion frigo est un vrai handicap
comme la croix rousse de sens ces
derniers mois plusieurs associations
caritatives ont été la cible de voleurs
l'an dernier les restos du coeur de joie
ni avait même subi trois cambriolages
d'affilée pour les bénévoles de sens pas
question de se décourager
même si le moral en prend un coup moi je
ressens de la colère
je trouve inadmissible qu'on puisse
voler des choses que ce soit nous la
croix rouge le camion les restos du
coeur se faire cambrioler on donne de
notre temps et en plus on nous impacte
en nous faisant du mal donc c'est une
hanche et jus non je trouve ça
complètement aberrant face à l'urgence
de la situation
la croix-rouge de sens cherche
aujourd'hui un nouveau camion
frigorifique
ne reste plus qu'à trouver un généreux
donateur